DOW FINISHED DOWN 167.
S&P 500 WAS OFF 15.
NASDAQ DROPPED 16.
WE BEGIN OUR MIDTERM ELECTION
COVERAGE TONIGHT WITH NEW
INSIGHT ON SOME OF THE KEY RACES
IN THIS FALL'S MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
IT'S THE FIRST OF MANY STORIES
ON THE HOTTEST CONTEST LEADING
UP TO NOVEMBER.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY LOOKS
AT NEW INFORMATION ON THE
BALANCE OF POWER.
>> IF DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
TURN THIS AND IT BLEW THIS FALL,
THEY'VE GOT A HEAVY LIFT BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE ONLY DEFENDING
EIGHT SEATS.
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS OR
SIT WITH THEM, 26.
TO TILT THE CHAMBER, DEMOCRATS
NEED TO WIN, THAN TO REPUBLICANS
NEED TO LOSE.
INCUMBENTS INCLUDE TEN DEMOCRATS
WHO REPRESENT STATES
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON.
THE DEMOCRATIC SENATORIAL
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE SAYS THAT
SENATE DEMOCRATS FACING
CHALLENGING MAP BUT REPUBLICANS
ARE FACING EXPENSIVE AND
DIVISIVE PRIMARIES AN ELECTORATE
THAT IS REPULSED BY THEIR
AGENDA.
THE NATIONAL REPUBLICAN
SENATORIAL COMMITTEE IS TRYING
TO CAST THE MOST VULNERABLE IS
VERY PROGRESSIVE, TELLING FOX
THAT THESE RED STATE DEMOCRATS
VOTED AGAINST THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA AT EVERY TURN.
THEY HAVE ZERO EXPLANATION FOR
WHY THEY SIDED WITH ELIZABETH
WARREN AND VOTING AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TAX PLAN.
SPEAK OF THE DEMOCRATS RUNNING
THESE RACES ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A MESSAGE THAT ISN'T TOO
CRITICAL OF TRUMP WHILE
TRYING TO WIN OVER THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE.
>> FOX NEWS POWER RANKINGS HAVE
FOUR SEATS LEANING DEMOCRATIC.
OHIO, PENNSYLVANIA, NEVADA,
MONTANA.
SHE STATES LEADING REPUBLICAN.
INDIANA AND TENNESSEE WHERE BOB
CORKER IS RETHINKING HIS
RETIREMENT.
THEN THERE ARE THE TOSS-UP'S.
ARIZONA, MISSOURI, NORTH DAKOTA,
WEST VIRGINIA FLORIDA WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ALREADY
ENDORSED OUTGOING
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT.
NOVEMBER'S 36 GOVERNORS RACES
REPRESENTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DEMOCRATS.
>> THE ISSUES ARE DIFFERENT.
THEY ARE NOT TURNING ON FEDERAL
ISSUES.
THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT GOVERNING
STYLE AND NOT TIED INEXTRICABLY
TO DONALD TRUMP OR REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS.
>> IN THE HOUSE WERE DEMOCRATS
NEED TO FLIP 24 SEATS TO WIN
CONTROL, DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
HAVE A 6.5. EDGE ON A BALLOT.
THEY ARE COUNTING ON A DIFFERENT
NUMBER TO CARRY THEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S APPROVAL.
38.8%.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT COME UP
WITH A UNIFYING MESSAGE.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO SAY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OTHER THEN
WE DON'T LIKE TRUMP.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR REPUBLICANS,
THAT MIGHT BE ENOUGH.
>> ANOTHER PILLAR OF THE
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGY IS TO
CRITICIZE THE TAX REFORM BILL.
THE SAME TAX FORM BILL
REPUBLICANS THINK IS THEIR
BIGGEST ADVANTAGE.
I HAVE OBTAINED INTERNAL RNC
POLLING THAT SHOWS MOST VOTERS